everyone's 2d Weintraub here I'm with
the director of petal ttan did I say
that right because I was I was so
nervous I was gonna say Paddington or
anything else is there a movie called
Paddington right we can't give them any
press we can that's a good movie but you
also made a good movie so there's
nothing I've seen it
Paddington - I'm already doing terribly
at this because I'm promoting another
film Paddington too has a hundred
percent on Rotten Tomatoes so go see
Paddington - I agree or paddle ttan
perhaps we should talk about that
completely up before we get started as I
was saying a second ago off-camera I
want to give a huge thank you to Kia
Telluride and all the other sponsors
here Sundance is really expensive
they've all been great I just want to
say sincerely thank you do you feel
refreshed
yeah thank you life water so talk a
little bit about how the project no one
will have seen it who's actually
watching the interview and I hate doing
the generic thing but talk a little bit
about like what it's about sure yeah
it's um it's a it's a story about these
two misfit buddies starring Ray Romano
and Mark Duplass these kind of strange
guys that are neighbors and best friends
and soul mates and it's a it's a
platonic romance you know between the
two of them bromance
as we call them and it's about it's a
film about letting go because the
younger guy mark actually gets diagnosed
with terminal cancer and his his only
friend in the world the guy that gets
him the most has to help him has to help
him die yeah so he's got eleven helping
let go one of the things that I applaud
you for is that this is not subject
matter that a lot of people tackle oh
it's a comedy I forget it's all about
timing right the jokes were better in
the film the but seriously the subject
matter is something that is it's it's
not talked about it's not common subject
matter in movies and TV we don't like to
talk about that exactly yeah
so was it tough putting the film
together in terms of finding someone
who's like I don't want to finance that
that's for me
well I mean I'm pretty lucky to be
working with people like you know
Duplass and Netflix that say like yeah
you want to make this the stone you
don't need to put a cape on them and we
can talk about the [ __ ] that's gonna
make people uncomfortable you know find
some humor make it entertaining cast
somebody that's gonna crack some great
jokes there's two people I guess but ya
know I think they they got it and we're
really lucky to be allowed to make a
movie like that I agree with you yeah a
lot of people are gonna get scared with
something that's gonna be depressing and
not marketable but you put it on Netflix
and it finds the right people I guess
the right people will find it completely
I heard they have an algorithm can't
confirm that right or deny it
exactly there is some great back and
forth between ray between your in your
cast and I'm just curious how much was
that on the page how much is that being
found in the moment or in rehearsals so
there isn't a ton of page it's not a
full script we didn't have a full script
we had a treatment we outlined you know
the beats of the story you know mark and
I wrote it together and then we did some
some rehearsals if you want to call him
that where you know mark and right now I
would just kind of shoot the [ __ ] and
talk about the scenes and you know Ray
would crack some jokes or like oh my god
kind of build a scene around a couple of
those jokes actually a couple yeah a
couple of moments in the movie or based
off of funny bits that he brought to it
that were you know somatically just just
made sense and were hilarious
but know a lot of it was building the
movie around those couple of sessions we
had on the phone and in person just kind
of vibing it out and then we improved
the a ton on set or I should say they
improved ton on set and I was trying to
keep up with you know the joke and the
jokes and the the shifting storyline
well see that brings me altum Utley the
edit is the final rewrite and I would
imagine when you have improvisers like
this it prevents both good things and
bad things in the Edit because you I'm
sure you had some scenes that were could
be played two different ways both of
which were great and which one do I do
yeah for sure
it was weird to me you know we shot this
relatively quickly for what a film you
know usually takes we shot like you know
three weeks but um it didn't really hit
me as to how much we shot until you know
Ray had seen a cut he's like wow I can't
believe you were able to pull it you
know we shot so much a nice thing like
wait Elmo is a three week movie and then
I realize like yeah we shot so much we
tried so much stuff and there's there's
you know a lot of beautiful funny
precious moments that you gotta let go
and that all happens in the Edit for
sure and I would have to attribute a lot
of that working with a really good core
producing team that um you know knows
how to see what's working and you know
help guide that stuff and and you know
we screened them the film with some
really smart filmmakers that we trusted
and kind of see like what's resonating
for you you know are we going to dark or
we you know are you guys loving these
characters as much as we are
so I'm major major team accomplishment
there where did the idea for kung-fu and
we don't want to make sure the death
punch death punch
yeah where'd that come from well we
should say in the movie death punch and
their relationship is they bond a lot on
kung-fu movies yeah they love kung fu
movies and frozen pizza and this made-up
game palette in' and yeah the the movie
death punch is their favorite movie and
obviously there's some themed attic
stuff there but it's just this uh this
little there's a kung fu movie idea I
had be kind of cool to make this and
then I realized it would fit into this
movie and so kind of got to make that
70s kung fu film within a film I want to
give it away too much but yeah I enjoyed
that and also obviously where did the
game come from the title of the movie we
made it out to be honest it was um it
was we scripted it as paladin just
because it was kind of like that's
that's a new made-up game whatever and
then um I just went out with a racquet
and just kind of tried to make up a game
with like a trash can and a ball bought
a bunch of different balls and it's like
trying to I don't know I mean didn't you
do that as a kid like it was not
you'd make up your own games isn't that
better than like any any organized sport
you could do is just like you kind of
screw around with whatever you know
tennis racket and ball and trash can and
you'd make something up
all right so the most important thing
about that game is that there's no
winner right it's a collaborative game
where these two guys are just trying to
win together which obviously has some
thematic undertone you filmed in a town
that I didn't even know existed in
California what am i solving exactly
where we find this town and tell people
about it
yeah it's just like Danish town that
it's like it was like air dropped like
from like straight out of Europe air
dropped into wine country California
it's very strange place some people
there's like all these tourists that go
there sort of for the wine tasting it's
right next to where they filmed sideways
another great movie you guys should see
we should keep luggage keep lugging
other movies also like Monty Python's
meaning of life but but but but it's
this like weird town that is really
quirky and although all the facades have
this you know Hans Christian Andersen
vibe to them and it just kind of fit you
know who the characters are like you
know just to quirky guys that don't
totally make sense but like are so
authentic and you can't stop
appreciating how different they're
completely but the thing is it's like
it's show it's visually like so
interesting and I just have never seen
it in movies before or if it's been
there I have not noticed I've wanted to
shoot something there for a while it's
only two hours from LA and actually yeah
I was like googling I was like it's like
looking up like there's got to be more
movies that have shot here so no it's
untapped which is crazy and like a lot
of people should go make their movies
there in like a year from now just give
us like a year you know because we
release on February 22nd on Netflix was
that a good segue that's kind of rough I
actually think it was a great segue and
letting people know that the movies
coming but talk a little bit about the
working for Netflix because I've spoken
to a lot of filmmakers yeah and everyone
says great things they just say yeah I
know but it could all be lying
yeah working with Netflix is great this
is my third
film with them and they're wonderful
they they get that like they should have
as many different voices and and and
tones and and as made different kinds of
films as possible because obviously that
gives people a broader selection then
you know it gives the viewers a sense of
choice and and and enjoy and picking the
things that they like one of the things
that I really appreciated about the film
is that it is it just plays everything
very realistically like it's a realistic
friendship it's not you're not trying to
you know what I mean and so talk about
capturing that yeah yeah like but just
talk a little bit about that like you're
not trying to Hollywood eyes what's
going on in terms of the disease and
stuff well the story is definitely about
the friendship to me and it's about
these two guys who we see him all the
time right in a pharmacy whatever guy
with the weird mustache or a fanny pack
or whatever no no offense the mustache
is fanny packs or anything but there's
that guy that it's really quiet maybe
seems a little weird to us if we're
being honest and just a little bit
judgmental and we have all these
preconceptions of this person and
usually we're not going to talk to them
and we just kind of like think like this
guy's probably weird and maybe creepy
what and at the end of the day they're
they're they're these real people with
feelings as well and like it was really
important to tell a story about two of
these guys who are loners who were lucky
enough to find each other their
friendship being incredibly important in
not feeling alone I think we all
obviously as humans are afraid to feel
alone and so it's yeah it's just it's a
story about that relationship and
there's nothing more authentic than
relationships I think completely I want
to say thank you so much for coming in
the studio I want to give again a huge
thank you to Kia Telluride and also I
hope people tune in on February 22nd on
Netflix yes so they can watch it if you
have a subscription it is free
fantastic yeah thank you and there's a
new feature as well you're not able to
turn it off if you don't like it
starting over 20 seconds so just just
hang in there not that you wouldn't like
it
this got awkward help me end this right
we can edit before that last sentence
[Laughter]
no seriously thank you for coming in
thank you
you